Je vous garantis qu'à un moment donné,
tout ira au sud pour vous
vraiment, vous allez dire que c'est comme
ça que je mets fin à l'affaire Marcus mort maintenant
vous pouvez soit accepter cela, soit vous pouvez vous
mettre au travail, ce sera un
sacré choc  à mes coéquipiers et à la fin
de la NASA du monde entier mais je suis toujours en vie
surprise voici le hic ça va prendre
quatre ans pour qu'une autre mission m'atteigne
et je vais avoir conçu pour durer
31 jours donc je dois faire de l'eau et grandir
de la nourriture sur une planète où rien ne pousse
mais si je ne peux pas trouver un moyen d'entrer en
contact avec la NASA, rien de tout cela n'a d'importance de
toute façon nous avons un message entrant le
mien a mon mur il est toujours en vie Wow
dans ton visage Neil Armstrong d'accord alors
allons-y  fais le calcul j'ai assez de nourriture pour tenir
50 jours il va mourir de
faim bien avant que nous puissions nous en servir je
vais devoir me débrouiller scientifiquement
il est à 50 millions de kilomètres de chez lui
il est totalement seul c'est lui
penser en ce moment je suis le plus grand
botaniste sur t  sa planète vous n'êtes pas une
marque de sauvegarde Watney mais nous avons besoin de l'
équipage Hermès nous avons soit une grande chance d'en
tuer un ou une petite chance d'en venir
six je ne risque pas leur vie c'est
plus grand qu'une personne non donc la
nasa a rejeté la mission  donc si
nous faisons cela, nous parlons de mutinerie, tout va
mal, nous l'avons fait, vous réalisez à quel point c'est fou,
nous n'avions pas d'autre option,
peu importe ce qui se passe, dites au monde
à ma famille,
n'arrêtez jamais de
vous battre.